The correct answer is Marcie.
To answer this question, we first want to look at the number of degrees of each node.
A degree is the number of edges coming in and out.
Tyrone is a node with degree 2.
Marcie a node with degree 3.
Sayo is a node with degree 2.
Christian is a node with degree 2.
Javier, our starting node, is a node with degree 3.
Hubert is a node with degree 2.
As we showed in lecture, in order for there to be an Eulerian path
every node in the network needs to have even degree,
except for the starting and ending nodes, which are odd.
In this example, Javier was our starting node and it had degree 3.
All the other nodes are even, except for Marcie, which has degree 3,
which is odd. Marcie will be our end node.